じゃあ温泉しましたカメラが治りましたやっぱり一例です
nex 祭文連今日はちょっと
最近の youtube について話そうと思いますさあ皆さん知ってる通りいった銀
僕の動画の再生回数が少ないですよね
見てわかると思うんですけど昔は
6番回再生とか7万回再生と加工
もう登録さ関係ないとんでもない数の再生回数が多かったんですけど最近の動画を見る
と
登録者より少ないぐらいの再生回数は動画がほとんどなんですけどこれもう終わりか
インクがなくなってきたもうやめときかもしれない youtube 卒業って持っ
てる方多いと思います始め冊を全然再生されてね
人気ねーじゃんと思うじゃないですか全然違います最近の動画見ても高評価の方が昔
より全然美味しへ応援してくれる方は確実に増えていってるんですよ
協力者も以前と同じまたはそれ以上の伸びを見せてて何が落ちてるか応援してくださっ
てる方が減ってるんじゃなくて
見る方が入っているその原因として
youtube が大きく変わったことがあるんですよね今 youtube が
すごい変わってるんですよ僕以外の
ユーチューバーさんの動画を見ても多分ものすごい再生回数減ってる人が多いと思い
ます
その一つの理由として
まあ youtube のトップページがなくなったということです
パソコンで見てる人あると思うんですけどトップベージがないんですよ
マイズ youtube のページにはトップベースというものがあってそこに
ランキングってー制度が android の人も youtube アプリを
アップデートしたら
ランキングっていう項目がなければなりませんですがそれも youtube の変革
性なんて
でこれ見てもらうと分かるんですけどどうですかこれ
課金300りんさん pdr さんそして俺
有名な方が中にズボンと向けがランクインしてたら誰もが思ういっしょ
ああ
そう思って僕の動画を見る人が多かったですね
その兄実は
ランキング制度にすごい乗ってて編んでから youtube が勝手に選んでくるん
ですけどすっごいランキングになってる[ __ ]もない動画を再生回送じゃないですか
パン食べたりジュース飲んだりするぞー
再生回数多いですけどその分低評価が多かったんです簡単じゃないですか関係ないとみ
られてないんですかどうか
前までトップベージランキングがあったから
何キングに乗ってると思ってなんとなーく見る人がたくさんいて
再生回数でもガーンってあったんですけど
外くん誰こいつと思って低評価が多かったんですけど最近動画いったらわかると思うん
ですけど低評価が異常に少ない
そういうことですよ今の動画は本当に
僕のチャンネルを登録してくれる方
暮らせ姉さんが来ないの
感じの人しか見られてないんですよ
ユーチューバーすごい変わっちゃったんですけどイメージ有名な人に動画見られなく
なくて叩かれなくなったっていうのはすごい嬉しかったんですけど
けどやっぱり僕的には実力じゃないにしてもそういう僕の動画見られる機会っていうの
が失われたっていうのは
間違いないことなんでじゃあなんで youtube はこんな事をしたかっていう
沐浴僕いつも見てる姉ちゃんって動画でも言ってたんですけど
youtube が悪い方に悪い方にいって進むわけがないんですよ
改善されたからには必ず理由があってもっと youtube をいいようにしようっ
ていう考えで
ユーチューバートップベージランキングはなくしたんだと思うんですけどこれ僕の考え
なんですけど
youtube はきっと
僕たちに
youtube の中でいばんじゃねーって言ってると思うんですよ
youtube の中で有名でも結局は youtube の中でしか有名じゃないっ
ていう
youtube もまだまだテレビと比べて弱いですねそこで youtube さん
は考えたんですよ
youtube に頼んじゃねぇ youtube 以外のところでもっと自分の
チャンネル動画そういうものをいろんな人に進めろ的なそうじゃないですかねその1
オズの例としては sns twitter とか facebook とかですよね
雑誌とかマスコミテレビ
そういう youtube 以外のところでもっと
youtube のことを宣伝してこうもっと
youtube にいろんな人と離婚でほしいっていうのは
youtube のでライナーじゃないでしょうか僕の勝手な
考えです
なんで今まで僕の再生回送方10日は僕の実力じゃなくて
youtube のトップベージランキングっていうものがあってこう
とカーンと
無差別に見られたらわけです決して皆さん心配しないで下さいね
僕の人気がなくなったとかそういう話じゃなくて
youtube 時代が変わってるんです youtube がこうだった以上
皆さんの力が必要です
もっといろんな人に絵封筒を見てもらうためには
youtube の中だけで頑張ってちゃうがメってことです動画を見て面白いとか何
か楽しいとかつまんねーとか
いろいろもうじゃないですか
それを
もっといろんな人とかいろんな場所に
広めて
濮陽僕の札やもっと youtube に人を集めていただきたいんです
youtube だけで頑張って他校ダメな youtube になりました
またちょっと僕は
何か新しいことをしていかなきゃいけないなって思っていいながら
youtube これからもしていくんですけど
まあこの音再生回数が少ないで言うと
youtube が変わりましたよっていう話でした